ladies and gentlemen welcome to a pilot
of a brand new
show i'm launching before i tell you the
title of it let me tell you
great ideas don't come from the vacuum
from the void it's a great myth you know
uh uh artists like myself
that sounds so pretty artists we steal
great artists steal guys but unlike what
kevin david thinks
you don't steal from one thing you take
from a variety of sources so
let me explain my inspiration for the
show before we get into the first
episode inspiration number one
sociopaths
sitting out there waiting to give you
their money are you gonna take it
are you man enough to take it that's one
of my favorite scenes
of all time second comedians in cars
getting coffee i'll explain and this
is comedians in cars getting coffee
right
it's catchy it's you gotta admit for
such a long time it's pretty
catchy so i thought i was cooking up in
the brain you know i was looking around
like is anyone gonna see
anyone stolen this idea already look new
show instituted right now sociopaths
on stage selling ponzies
kind of got a ring to it don't you think
and look guys yeah maybe it's a pilot
maybe we kick it off as a series maybe
netflix buys it i don't know pump the
stock that's all i
look are we worried about fundamentals
here are we pumping the stock what are
we doing here
now this is our boy today this is uh
sociopath number one now guys you know
guys i'm not a clinical psychologist
sociologist i'm not a doctor
i don't play one on the internet i do
jokingly
give my opinion on people okay you're
about to get sold
on a pretty amazing idea imagine let me
paint the picture for you
free money easy money guaranteed money
can't lose can't miss
money all with the power of imagination
actually sorry the internet the internet
with the power of the internet
kin and his wife carrie cortwright want
to buy you
or build you a profit generating website
that can make you
up to 20 of your money every year
like clockwork i've done guarantees in a
contract
uh which goes in perpetuity from as low
as 11
i've even done one as high as i think 23
24 oh wow
and that's not if it's successful that's
guaranteed
and in fact they said that if they don't
meet their side of the bargain they will
literally
remake the store for you so when crap
happens
we enact what's called the act of god
clause which is in the contract of our
arrangement
and it simply says it does not matter
the reason that this site is failing
it is failing so we're just going to set
it aside and build or buy a new one
and so on 18 times we have put up brand
new sites
at on at our dime and away they go do a
minimum monthly guarantee of x
amount so that it's comfortable for them
to deal in a territory typically unknown
which is websites making money personal
minimum
guarantees yikes guys nothing in life is
for sure
except for death and taxes well actually
taxes some people have figured out a way
out of that
like logan paul going to puerto rico but
anyways if you sign up now
ken and kerry courtright will not only
give you a guaranteed return
they'll actually raise it by a few
percent if you sign up right now you'll
work with bill
he'll add one to two percent onto the
guaranteed minimum return that you
receive
each month it's pretty cool pretty cool
guys guaranteed no risk which is pretty
cool
uh monthly revenue commitments go with
all sites
uh they might be as low as seven percent
they might be highest
in some cases depending on the platform
and what we're building
you might get into the mid sometimes
even the upper teens yeah guys that
means you put in 100k
let me translate this they will give you
up to seven
to like 20 return are you
hearing this there is no such thing as a
free lunch
but uh as you know in life if you
promise things
people will believe you and as such ken
and kerry courtright
have managed to persuade about 75
million dollars away
from investors they say they're so
professional don't they look trustworthy
guys
they just look like a couple of class
acts they wouldn't lie to you
he looks like a little boy scout leader
or something like that
he looks like he could be your state
senator what are you not gonna trust
this guy
well as you've already seen this pitch
is pretty slick
but sociopaths or or people doing bad
things
they have cracks appear in their speech
see if you can spot them
in order to in order to to eventually
retire you need to have a pile of money
you see that ken he's a bit uh
obsessed with how he looks on stage and
he really doesn't like his wife
who seems to not be as good on stage as
ken
and so during this speech he's
constantly monitoring her
controlling her and it's kind of weird
but he knows
in order to in order to true so of
course he does it once
all right so this is actually one of my
favorite because
well it's my opportunity to brag a
little bit okay my opportunity
and then again and then again nuts when
your friend co-worker or neighbor who's
not
i understand who's not happy
honey you've got to make sure the mic is
close to your mouth
while we pitch this ponzi scheme listen
when you say guaranteed returns you got
to put the
mic close to your mouth she's like i
understand you
psychopath you put me up there all good
things must come to an
end and the sec brought the hammer
down these two have been accused of
operating a ponzi like
scheme under the name of the income
store in exchange for an investor's
upfront fee
they claimed they'd be able to build
this website and of course they were not
in fact
they were funding their lifestyle with
the returns from investors and with the
money from investors
according to some estimates of over half
of the money will never be returned
to the investors which is extremely sad
because it was over 75
million dollars at the same time guys
let this be a lesson to everyone
these psychopaths will always be out
here dressed in new clothes
right have you ever heard the expression
wolf in sheep's clothing
that's the feeling i get like my skin
crawls
it's like they portray this image of oh
we're just
we're just family loving people right uh
in reality
they're greedy they stole old people's
money i mean they stole everybody's
money
and it's absolutely disgusting the way
they stand up there portraying
themselves to be the good guys they're
the heroes right
that want to help you i mean i really
want you guys to pay attention
to how these two talk they talk like
they've descended out of heaven above to
help you out it's
unbelievable okay so guys with that can
you just give the listeners a little bit
more about
your background and what got you to
where you are today yeah so we uh we
actually started about 30 years ago
came out of college we met in college
and we just had a crazy idea that we
could walk into business donors and
tell them that we could grow their
business and they should pay us that
didn't go too well the first year but
over time through a few testimonials uh
we did talk a few people into letting us
attempt to grow their business and
turned out we were successful so
uh but in 2009 uh something happened and
that was where we came face to face with
the fact that the internet
is real it's not a fad it's here to stay
and we
think it should be the centerpiece of
growth for most companies moving forward
so we changed our
growth consulting model and made a
statement that we will only grow a
business or a household by
adding a money making website to them so
it allowed for a second third fourth
some even have a seventh eighth ninth
revenue stream on top of their main in
revenue stream
and so we either build them or buy them
a website that makes money and then our
200 employees manage it for them
for a share of the revenues incredible
because in actuality none of that was
happening i mean i know for a fact that
they did try to buy
some websites and they were not
successful they were not making the
returns they said they were making
and they instead were living out this
nice life
of sending their kids to private schools
buying expensive houses
all so they could just tell everybody
we're we're living the life
we can help you too and it was all a
complete
lie so what can we learn from all this
well true passive income which is the
holy grail of what most people think
they need
is actually very hard to come by and you
should be immediately
suspicious of anyone who promises you
any kind of guaranteed returns in
perpetuity
it doesn't exist folks it's like the
perpetual energy machine
it's been promised year after year after
year decade after decade as long as
mankind has been around
and it's always been a farce i've done
guarantees in a contract
which goes in perpetuity from as low as
11
i've even done one as high as i think 23
24 oh wow
listen to that that is the most
psychopathic thing
you could say either that guy is the
dumbest person on the planet
or he is um negligent to a level that is
unbelievable and he does face these
charges from the sec at this point
and it looks like he will be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
and i think he deserves it but remember
when you look at these guys
on stage they don't look like
conman unless you i mean unless you look
think this
type of couple looks like common maybe
they do to you
but to most people they look like your
typical middle-of-the-income road joes
that just want to help you out they're
well-dressed
professionals who are stealing your
money right under your nose
so i'm glad it looks like the income
store is shut down
for good and i can only hope that people
stop
falling for these things let this be a
lesson guys that's why i do the scammer
history is so that you can watch these
and not get scammed in the future
because these have been happening
forever so thank you so much for
watching i hope you learned something
hope you took something away
don't fall for the perpetual money
machine and i will see you guys
tomorrow